[Music]
and thank you for joining us as we kick
off our primary night coverage i'm brian
loftis i'm denise valdez results still
coming in at this hour but we'll start
with a few key races in our state we can
tell you tonight that right now it looks
like adam laxalt will be moving on
beating a sam brown from 55 percent to
35 percent again he's going to be facing
senator catherine cortez masto who
easily won her
at least this point her primary election
the two of them again facing off in
november now cortez masto sent a
statement saying in part adam laxalt was
a corrupt ag who led trump's efforts to
overturn the 2020 election on top of
that he opposes a woman's right to
choose
joe lombardo is maintaining a lead over
joey gilbert for the republican
gubernatorial nomination as we take a
look here across some of the four top
vote getters tonight steve sisilak also
easily winning the democratic nomination
in the gubernatorial race while turnout
for the primary election isn't as strong
as november races the local election
department was no doubt busy over the
last 24 hours let's go live to christian
casares who is at the headquarters up in
north las vegas now with more christian
well brian good evening to you let me
tell you this process of course is a
very long we're told that most of the
125 poll location teams have made their
way here to this facility here in north
las vegas but as you can see there's
still some staff here behind me they're
waiting for some of those crews to make
their way here to this location now some
of those crews we have to remember
they're coming from all over southern
nevada including mesquite and laughlin
now the process to count every single
vote is still underway here metropolis
of course has had a very heavy presence
inside and outside the facility
throughout the entire day now we did
speak to joe gloria with the register of
voters and he tells us the day overall
ran smoothly no major issues to report
at any of the poll locations but the
process itself is tedious
there's a lot of paperwork that we have
to verify and make sure that sales are
correct for our transfer cases where our
cartridges come in securely and also
that the mail ballot drop off boxes are
all brought in so that we can secure
them here for the night and verify the
seals
all right we'll back out here live glory
also telling us that
during the morning well they did see a
slow start but turnout increased in the
afternoon now some voters that dropped
off their ballots at this location today
told us safety education and the economy
were the top concerns that motivated
them to come out and vote during this
election but again the work still not
over at this facility we were told that
the votes that have been counted for are
from early voting and election day votes
we've got to remember that there's still
ballots out in the mail and of course
those are expected to be accounted for
very soon that's the latest here from
north las vegas live local now